protests across the nation over the
death of George Floyd are forcing
parents to have tough conversations
about racism with their children we
spoke to several kids about their
feelings on race and police violence and
as you'll hear they have some very
strong opinions
[Applause]
I think that there's a lot of injustice
because we're peacefully protesting
police brutality and then police
brutality is happening at the same time
someone that are supposed to like
protect us actually and kill
and we are black people you can't really
change us just cuz you treat us on
friends that's not really gonna affect
me because I'm proud of Who I am
Ebru max Ken D is author of the upcoming
book anti racist baby about how to raise
anti-racist kids
he's a CBS News contributor and joins us
now Abram good morning I want to point
out just there was a six year old girl
as we saw Ayanna they're talking which
which shows you even really young kids
are feeling what's going on right now so
how should parents be talking to them
about this whole question of racial
justice well actually I think we should
first emphasize that parents should be
talking to their children because I
think many parents believe that that
babies are colorblind that young
children are colorblind and but the
studies say differently as early as
three months babies look more at the
faces of people whose race matches their
caregivers as early as two years old
children discern people's behaviors
based on their race and and so we should
be having these conversations about race
we should be trying to teach our
children that all the racial groups are
equals that we live in a beautiful
rainbow of colors and and they're all on
the same level and they're on equal yeah
and they're also taking their cue from
our own behavior aren't they Oh without
question if someone wants to raise a
child who believes in justice who's
who's striving to the anti-racist who
believes in equality it's important for
them to be that themselves I mean you
know we teach our children our
philosophy and so it's important we
teach them in equitable philosophy we
had a protester earlier in the broadcast
a young african-american woman who said
when your complexion is a weapon
you're never unarmed and and you've
written about this very subject as a as
a black parent what do you what do you
tell a black kid right now I think you
can simultaneously talk to a black child
about how because of the color of your
skin
people are gonna view you is dangerous
people are gonna view you as violent but
you know what you are not dangerous
you are not violent there's nothing
wrong with you and if someone thinks
there's something wrong with you that
means something is wrong with their
ideas and you have to always remember
that and and so just is it's critical
for parents of color of children of
color to teach their children there's
nothing wrong with them
there's nothing inferior about them it's
critical for white parents to teach
their children there's nothing superior
about them you say parents need to be
anti-racist themselves in order to to
raise anti-racist so if you're if you're
a white parent at this moment how do you
model that to your kids I think you
model that to your to your kids by
recognizing the true source of the
problem right now and the true source of
that problem is is police brutality and
the source of that source is racist
policy is the racist ideas that pervade
American policing and you should then be
figuring out okay how can I contribute
to the resistance to the struggle
against racism in this country by
joining organizations supporting
organizations supporting policy makers
who are trying to dismantle on
institutional racism and race this
policy and as you point out here um I
think the most important thing is that
you recognize is your kid your kids are
feeling all of this you need to talk to
them ebrill mex kandi thank you and
anti-racist baby will go on sale June
16th on today's CBS this morning podcast
Abram discusses racial inequality white
privilege and police reform with author
and activist Tim Wise